RETO MEIER: All right.
Good afternoon, everyone.
Welcome to this year's
Android Fireside Chat.
My name is Reto Meier.
I'm part of the developer
relations team at Google
and I'm joined by some of
the most important people
on the Android Engineering,
Design and Product teams.
The purpose of the
fireside chat is basically
to let you guys ask questions
from these people, all
of the stuff that you want
to know about Android,
where it is, what
we've announced today,
how things have been done,
how some of those decisions
have been made, all of
those sorts of things.
So it is a Q&A session.
We have mics at the front
and middle of the room.
If you have a question,
please line up, ask.
If there are no questions,
it'll be a really short session.
We do have a few
from online which
we've collected in
the weeks leading up.
So I'm going to ask
some of those as well.
While you guys are getting
ready to ask questions yourself,
I'll ask the panel to
introduce themselves,
just who you are
and a little bit
about what you do at Google.
Maybe start with you, Gabe.
GABE COHEN: I'm Gabe Cohen.
I'm a product manager
on the Android OS.
I also work on
Google Play services
and a few other things.
XAVIER DUCROHET: Hello,
I'm Xavier Ducrohet.
I'm the lead for the
Developer Tool and the SDK.
ADAM POWELL: I am
Adam Powell I'm
a framework engineer
on the UI Toolkit.
RACHEL GARB: Hi.
I'm Rachel Garb and I'm
an interaction designer
on the Android OS.
JHILMIL JAIN: Hi.
My name is Jhilmil Jain and I
lead user research for Android.
CHET HAUSE: I'm Chet Hause.
I'm an engineer on
the UI Toolkit team.
DIANNE HACKBORN: I
am Dianne Hackborn.
I'm an engineer on the
Android Core Framework team.
DAVE BURKE: Dave Burke.
Engineering Director.
I work on the Platform
and Nexus devices.
FICUS KIRKPATRICK:
I'm Kirkpatrick.
I work on the Play Store
apps and games and hardware.
MILES BAR: I'm Miles Bar,
I'm the engineering manager
for the apps part
of Google Play.
RETO MEIER: Thanks everyone.
All right.
Let's get started.
We've got a line at the back.
So, why don't we
start with you, sir.
AUDIENCE: My question
is about Java 8.
Will it be coming to Android?
And if so, when?
And will it be supported on
all the versions as well?
RETO MEIER: It's like
a hot potato question.
Oh, the mic's going to Xav.
CHET HAUSE: Usually any question
that has the word will in it,
you might want to
think about it.
Because I'm not sure the answer
is going to be what you want.
In general, can we say the
general policy, which is,
we don't really talk about stuff
that we will do in the future.
Just so you know.
Let's just lay the
groundwork out there.
Xav, go.
RETO MEIER: Now,
answer the question,
Xav, What will happen and when?
[LAUGHTER]
XAVIER DUCROHET:
I have no comment.
[LAUGHTER]
RETO MEIER: Perfect.
All right.
Now you can all see me as well.
Let's try another question.
Hopefully one which we
can actually answer.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
This is for Dianne.
First off, I really
appreciate all
of the work you've
done on Binder.
And I know that it sits at
the heart of everything that
is Android at all.
And I just wanted
to ask you, you've
been involved in
Binder development
even before Android was Android.
Can you talk a little bit
about the history of Binder
and your work with it?
DIANNE HACKBORN: OK.
Well, thank you.
Oh, well I, So Binder
started out in BOS
and has been
something that I was--
I was not main person
who did Binder.
I worked on it as an engineer
at BE, then at Palm Source.
And then we kind of adopted
it just for IPC in Android.
But actually, I don't even
think it's the core of Android.
It's a convenient way to
do IPC on the Android.
Previous versions of the Binder
were actually much more core
to the platform design.
So today it's a really nice
way to do capability based IPC.
RETO MEIER: Fair enough.
Thank you.
All right, I'm going to ask one
of the questions we received
online earlier.
I think material design is one
of the most interesting things
that I saw come out
of the keynote today.
So I was wondering,
what sort of research
did we do to be able to come
up with some of those ideas?
JHILMIL JAIN: Thanks.
I think for the
first time at Google,
the researchers came
together across the company
to work on medieval design.
So we had researchers
from 15 different groups
and four different Google
offices come together
to do research.
And we conducted research
on four main areas.
The first was components, which
is containers and elements,
patterns and layouts, which
is like the floating action
button, motion
and accessibility.
So some examples of
the types of research
that we did, was first,
we explored and validated
key design principles,
such as really figuring out
the motion curve and speed.
Second was that we highlighted
key usability issues
that designers
should be mindful of.
For example, when picking the
color of the floating action
button, making sure
that it doesn't
blend into the background
like it was in some mocks
that we exploded earlier.
Or making sure that the
fabs, the size of the fab
wasn't, or floating
action button
wasn't like varying
within the app
because that would
confuse users.
And third is that we
conducted a whole bunch
of accessibility
studies that led
to a number of design changes.
And one such design
change is that we
have now a much improved
color palette, which
takes into account the
color contrast that
is required between
type and the background.
So now our low,
vision impaired users
can actually read the
text a lot better.
DAVE BURKE: If you're wondering
what a floating action
button is, because I didn't know
what it was until a week ago,
it's actually an image view.
It's where someone's called
set elevation on the view.
Just thought you should know.
But it looks cool.
And it's round.
Does it have to be round?
So the dialer one's the
floating action button.
We need a translation
between you and engineering.
RETO MEIER: Question
for Xav, I think.
I will quote it out to you.
Considering its performance,
why not offer Genymotion
as the official
emulator for Android?
[LAUGHTER AND CHEERS]
XAVIER DUCROHET:
It's a good question.
First of all, I think
it's a great product.
I think they are not
quite free, though.
So there is a demo version.
I don't know exactly
what the demo is.
But I think that's
what I sense, that you
have to pay for to
get some things.
So we can't quite
distribute that.
The other thing is
that, obviously, we
need to improve a
lot, the story there.
We have, one other thing
that we really want to do
is a low eliminating
already, all the ecosystem.
And that means
also AUM and MEEPS.
And they go mostly with
x86 for performance reasons
which totally makes sense.
But we have to sleep on that.
And we do want to support a lot
more hardware in the long term,
like Bluetooth, multi-touch,
and things like that.
And it's a lot
better, if we control
the own stack, the
whole stack for that.
And so we want to keep
all technology to do that.
But it's a great product.
You should definitely
try it out and use it
if it fits your needs.
RETO MEIER: Thanks.
Let's take another question
from the crowd, at the back.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
Just curious in
Android L, what's
new with adaptive bit rate
video and HLS support?
DAVE BURKE: OK.
So, let's see.
The most interesting
thing we're doing.
And I'm not sure if
it's launched yet
but it's imminent
is, we're going
to open source something
we call XO Player.
This is the player that's in
YouTube and in Play Movies
and TV.
And it's built on MediaCodec,
MediaDRM, and MediaExtractor,
MediaCrypto.
It's a really good
adaptive bit rate player.
It uses Dash.
So that's one thing to know.
And then I'm pretty sure we've
updated to the latest internet
draft of HLS in
L. And that's all
I can remember that
we've done so far.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
RETO MEIER: From the front.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I've seen the new
UI and UX you have
prepared for the L release.
I was wondering, I've seen
that in the action bar, where
we used to have the up
navigation affordments, now
we have what looks
like a back button.
What's going on there?
Is it changing?
Are we giving up on
the app navigation?
So what's going to happen?
ADAM POWELL: So the short answer
is that structurally nothing
is changing in that navigation.
Some of the stuff
that was shown,
I think during
the keynote, there
was a demo of multiple
Chrome tabs opening
in different documents
within recents as well.
So some of that is going
to subtly change just
as a result of that new feature.
In terms of the
iconography, unfortunately I
don't think we have
a representative
from our visual
design team here,
but Rachel do you
want to talk to that?
RACHEL GARB: Yeah, I believe
it's just that an arrow really
clearly says for most people,
this is what I wanted to do.
want do what I was doing before.
Whether it's hierarchical
or historical.
AUDIENCE: Don't we have
the back button for that?
ADAM POWELL: There is.
And what, Go ahead Feel free.
So what we found is that,
and again, even just
in terms of some of the research
that we've done with this,
users tend to really
think either in terms
of the system or the app
at a given point in time.
And having that extra
affordance be sitting there
in the app, very clearly
in the app in the bar,
is something that they
much more closely tie to,
I'm going to continue acting
within the context of this app.
Whereas the Back
button in the system
is really seen as more
of kind of meta action
that can act between apps.
Even though a lot
of users aren't
able to clearly articulate the
difference between these two,
and even though the iconography
is very similar, what we found
is a lot of users tend to
develop this really intuitive
understanding of what to expect
when they press either one.
Now, of course for developers,
this is really interesting
because it means that there's
a lot of subtlety to really get
this right.
And we're really hoping that
some of the new functionality
that we've exposed to open
documents in more recents tabs
will really help iron out
some of the rougher cases that
have come up along with this.
So definitely stay tuned
for more of the published
guidelines around how
to use that effectively.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
RETO MEIER: Thanks.
So I think seeing the
keynote this morning
and all of the awesome
changes from material design
and how good that
makes apps look,
I think one of the
questions that I have,
and I think, some
other developers,
how much work is
it going to take
to get an existing app
which already looks good,
follows the Android
design guidelines,
and turn it into
something that's
a great example of a material
design implementation?
CHET HAUSE: A bit.
RETO MEIER: Thank you, Chet.
GABE COHEN: I think
you were supposed
to plug the talk for tomorrow.
CHET HAUSE: Right, so,
Go see the talk tomorrow.
Answer over.
So, in fact, there's two
talks on material design,
sort of the engineering side
of that one with Adam at 11.
So you can go there if you want
a little bit more information
about there, where we talk
about things like this.
So there's sort of a
gradient of how much work
you want to take on to get
toward the vision of what
your material
design app will be.
The first step is not that bad.
Which is basically enable
the material theme.
then, if you're using
custom apps, custom views,
in your system, then you may
need to fix up some of those.
If you have assets
that were created
with other themes
in mind, maybe they
look a little bit out of place.
So we basically see it
as enable the theme, spot
fix as necessary.
And that's kind of the minimum
bar to be a material app.
And then after that,
you can say, well,
what is the material
design actually going
to be for this app,
with different padding,
different lay out, and then what
does that necessitate in terms
of the functionality that
I need to change in my app.
And then, you can figure
out how far down that road
you want to go.
And I should also point
out that a lot of that work
is actually just using
APIs that already exist.
They're not new APIs
in L. So it's not
like we expose this huge new
surface area of APIs in L
that you have to use
to be a quantum app.
It's more that we
have new capabilities
to do things like
Real-Time Shadows
that we use internally to
get elevation for views
when appropriate.
You can access
those if you want,
if it's appropriate
for your application.
But most of what
we're talking about
is simply new design
along the paradigm
that we talked about
with material design.
And then the work that you need
to do, just traditional Android
development work for layouts
and padding and assets
to realize that design.
ADAM POWELL: The nice
thing a lot of this,
as well, is that if you
followed some of the design
evolution of a lot
of big Android apps
in the last few years, you'll
notice that a lot of them
have been moving in this sort
of direction to begin with.
You'll see that a lot of things
are contained on surfaces.
You have drawers that slide out
over scrolling areas of cards.
You have a lot of these
very similar patterns that
have really been kind of
kicked up for material design
and refined.
So if you've been sort
of following along
in a lot of the footsteps that
have been blazed before this,
then I think you'll find that
the workload to really go
that extra step isn't
quite as much as it
looks like in the first glance.
GABE COHEN: I should also
say material design's one
of the big drivers behind
us doing the L Developer
Preview this year.
I definitely recognize that
it's going to take, quote,
a bit of effort for people
to adapt their apps.
We wanted to give people time to
do that in advance of consumers
getting the full sweep of apps
from Google in that theme.
But we also want to
give people a chance
to give us feedback on
where it works for them.
Where it doesn't.
What sort of patterns
they want to express
in this design language.
And hopefully hear
back from people about
how it fits with their
design ethos in their brain.
Looking forward to that.
RETO MEIER: And that's
a really important thing
as well, like one of the big key
things about doing a Developer
Preview like this is that we
want to hear from you guys
as to what works, what
doesn't work, what you love,
start to see some of that stuff.
So tell us.
Let's see, from the front.
AUDIENCE: First off, I
want to thank all of you
seriously for your
work on the platform
and on developer relations.
You make my life a lot better.
So, thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
So my question.
I've noticed a lot of
differing perspectives
from different developers.
And some developers who
just throw up their hands
and say, I'm confused
about when it's
appropriate to use
an activity with one
fragment or an activity
with a bunch of fragments,
like a dozen or an activity
with two different fragments
or maybe, is it ever
appropriate these days
to use an activity
with no fragments?
And I know that's
nuanced, but I'd really
appreciate if we could talk
through it a little bit.
DIANNE HACKBORN: I'll start.
One of the basic
things is that you're
going to have at
least one activity.
And you'll probably have
multiple activities.
So you should
think of activities
as being the entry points
into your application.
Android doesn't have like
one main entry point.
It has more than one.
And so activities
are the top things,
that if someone is going to
go into your application,
that's how they get into it.
And then once you're inside
the activity, the right way
to do things is,
from my perspective,
now, Adam add to this,
but from my perspective,
as far as the system
management, that's really
up the application.
Now, the application
has the freedom to say,
if it makes sense now to
have multiple fragments,
to have one fragment, to
have no fragments, however
it wants organize it, there's
not concrete rules on that.
ADAM POWELL: So I would
say that one of the rules
to follow with that is,
[LAUGHTER]
DIANNE HACKBORN: Nonconcrete.
ADAM POWELL: Not
a concrete rule.
Rule of thumb, maybe,
is just kind of look
to the name of the API.
It's a fragment, it's a piece.
It is a piece of an
activity if you're
finding that your
activity is just
getting too big and
unwieldy and too much
code to think about
in one go, then
maybe it's worth
breaking some of that
up into some more
logical fragments.
I mean, keep in mind that
both activities and fragments
fulfill the role of being
a controller in sort
of your whole model
view controller
setup of your application.
So as long as it makes
sense to break that
down into smaller more
understandable pieces, then
maybe it makes sense
to break that down
into some more fragments.
DIANNE HACKBORN:
I would also add,
I think a very
reasonable approach
is to say, just implement
everything as fragments.
So all your UI
elements are fragments
and then you put
those into activities
where it makes sense.
Right?
Because fragments are
the more flexible way
to organize your application.
And so if you find, like, I have
this UI element here and now
in the future I need
it somewhere else,
it's really nice that, instead
of having implemented it
as an activity, you have
it there as a fragment
and it can be fairly reasonable
to other parts of the UI.
ADAM POWELL: Just think of it
as another unit of abstraction
that's available to you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
RETO MEIER: From the back.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
I would like to understand
what your experience is
with your own usage of
permissions in Android,
as a user of Android.
And what user research
you might have
and I wanted to give you
some feedback from the Wild
West of developing, which is
our users may not have a Google
approved version of Android.
So anywhere in my
code that I'm calling
for system resources or
assistant managers of any kind,
I need to protect that.
I need to be prepared for,
although I got the permission,
because they installed
it, it might not be there.
And where I'm
going with this is,
I like the way you've
simplified, recently,
the presentation
when you install.
But where can we go
with dynamic permissions
because I think that
helps users to understand
the context with which
a permission is used.
So what can you tell me about
the research that's going on
and what you use.
Do you just hold your
nose and install?
I mean that seems like a
normal thing to do to me.
JHILMIL JAIN: All right.
So I'll talk from a
research perspective
and then Dave or
somebody else will
talk from a framework
perspective.
So from a research
perspective I do
realize that we can do a lot
more to provide transparency
with the permissions.
I know one thing is that, OK, I
have accepted these permissions
to install an app.
How was this data being showed?
Shared with other
third party maybe.
Or is there was
one place where I
can go to sort of manage
all my permissions.
So these are things
that we are aware of.
And we are deeply
thinking about this.
So stay tuned.
FICUS KIRKPATRICK: Yeah.
I just wanted to comment on a
couple things you mentioned.
I think there was a lot to
unpack in that question.
But around, I guess,
having to code defensively
around incompatible versions
of Android and so on.
I'd be curious if
you tell me afterward
what particularly that is
because we work on the Play
Store and you may
have heard of it.
It runs on a lot of devices
and it's just not something
that we've run into of
seeing this inconsistent
availability of permissions,
whether they're granted or not.
RETO MEIER: I suspect
you may be referring
to some of the problems which
have come out which allow users
to optionally disable some of
the permissions which you may
have been granted
through installation.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Thank you.
FICUS KIRKPATRICK: I
think that, thank you
for the feedback on the way
we display permissions now.
I think the big
insight there was
we had tied the developers idea
for the permission and the user
idea for the permission
together for a long time.
I think what the users
care about is the data.
So I think that we're just
getting started on figuring out
how people think about what
data they're getting access to.
You saw some of the stuff in
the keynote today about data
control is something users want.
I think you're seeing
the first step.
And the research is going
to, the research we've done
is going to inform where the
platform goes going forward.
Gabe do you want to, do you
want to talk about app ops.
GABE COHEN: Also, thank
you for the feedback
on the simplification.
Actually you ask for personal
anecdotes or experience.
I think I'm similar to
many users in that there's
a service I want.
And there's a certain
number of things
I'm willing to bear to get it.
And sometimes I just want
that service and that's
kind of the end of
the conversation.
And for users who may be looking
for more commodity experience,
I think the difference in
permissions between apps
will actually make a
difference in what they choose.
We hope the new
UI makes it clear
what those differences
are between apps.
And then anecdotally, what I've
heard from friends and family
after we did the roll out,
they're like, what is this?
Is that generally they're
noticing them more.
I think our goal is to give a
more gestalt impression, using
iconography and
things like that.
And that's having an effect.
People are like, wow, this
application can do this stuff.
Actually it could
always do that stuff,
you couldn't tell
because it was buried
in a mess of information.
We really uplifted
the signal there.
And I guess for your question
about context and run time.
I think we would all
agree that context
helps users make decisions.
We just haven't come
up with the right way
to incorporate that
into the experience yet.
But like Jhilmil said, we're
still thinking about this.
I think we have a
long way to go still.
ADAM POWELL: And just to your
point about your experience
as a developer, I think that's a
great example of the experience
that we don't want.
And users are our developers
as engineers on the platform.
So I think that as we continue
thinking about this problem,
we're really going
to try and find
where that balance is between
user's needs and developer's
needs and make sure that
everybody can kind of come
to some agreements.
AUDIENCE: Thanks guys.
RETO MEIER: So another
question from online.
Asks, are there any plans to
improve the Android activity
life cycle stack.
In particular making it
less complex for developers
to deal with.
DIANNE HACKBORN:
Well, less complex.
Well since this question
did not say anything
about exactly what was wrong,
I'm going to make that up.
[LAUGHTER]
So one perspective on
this is that Android
took a quite different approach
from a traditional operating
system to what an
application is,
in that normally an operating
system in an application
is basically a main.
And the platform just
says, OK, the user
wants to run this
application main go.
And at that point,
the application
is all in control of what's
going on inside of it.
And the platform doesn't really
have any control over it.
So when we did Android,
one of the basic things
we wanted to do
is, we say we don't
want to have just
a main entry point.
Because we want to have
a lot more interesting
interactions across
applications.
And so we have this
activity component model.
This activity is
services, receivers,
and stuff that make
up all the entry
points into the application.
So once you do that,
you kind of can't
have just this main black
box application that is just
this box, you make it run
and it does its thing.
Because the operating
system actually
needs to have a lot
more interaction
with the application about,
oh, it's made this activity.
But now someone wants to share.
And so now we need to
make another activity.
And we have to tell the
application to do that.
And the application has
to always be in a state
that it can do that.
Because it can't know when
this is going to happen.
So that's where a lot of
that complexity comes in.
And it's really, I
think, about-- it's
this change from the
app developer being
in control of its
box to needing to do
some coordination
with the platform.
And it may be some complexity.
I think there's it's
maybe more learning curve.
I really think that
once you get through
that, there's a lot
of advantages to us,
certainly for
developing the platform,
it's given us a lot
of opportunities
to do new features
in the platform
with existing applications
and ways we never
could have without this.
And one example in
L that I love is
that we introduced
this whole recents
with this document
oriented recents
that applications have
multiple recent entries.
And if you run the developer
preview, you're going to see,
we're actually doing this
to existing applications.
So if you do a share, and you
go through the standard share
dialogue, when you end
up in the share target,
this becomes another
entry on recents.
And now you can
switch back and forth
between the original
application and the thing
you're sharing to.
And we can do this
because we made this break
between the application
being this black box
and the something that the
platform coordinates with more.
So, if that's the
kind of complexity
you're talking about,
I think that, yes,
there is a learning curve on it.
It's a little more complex, but
I think it actually gives us
a lot of benefit going forward.
DAVE BURKE: I don't know if
you guys just noticed that.
I see this about every month
where Dianne goes, yeah,
we designed this
thing four years ago
because we knew
that tomorrow we're
going to want to work this way.
So she's this always happens.
Great.
RETO MEIER: Thanks, Dianne.
From the front of the room.
AUDIENCE: So I was wondering
if you guys, at any point,
consider the support,
the official support,
of the Scala
programming language.
I'm asking this
question, especially,
I know that we also
that Apple already
has Swift after
four years of work.
And I think that Swift does
all those things for us
as developers that
we can't do in Java.
And with the Android SDK.
So my question was, have
you ever thought about it,
before the release of Swift?
Have you thought
about it after that?
And is there any plan?
DAVE BURKE: Well,
so I like Cocoa,
but Objective-C is based
on C which is 40 years old.
So I think Apple sort of
had to update it a bit.
I don't know.
Scala, I don't know.
Anyone want to take that?
DIANNE HACKBORN: No.
[LAUGHTER[
Seriously, Java is the
programming language
for Android, you
know, I don't really
think there's a lot benefit to--
The entire framework is built
around the Java
programming language.
And I don't think there's
much benefit for us
to try to support another
whole other different language.
AUDIENCE: What about Swift?
DIANNE HACKBORN:
I'll think about it.
DAVE BURKE: It's not
optional semicolons.
DIANNE HACKBORN:
You have the NDK.
So if you want to throw
something in there.
But the NDK, it doesn't have
access to the framework.
Right?
And that's kind of
the challenge is
if you want to do a
different language,
if you want to have it as
a first class language,
equivalent to the
current framework,
you've got to have either
a whole new framework
or some bindings to
it, which is going
to make it a really
bad experience
because it's going to be
Java in this other language.
AUDIENCE: I'm in a
country that always
to work with Scala because Scala
is compared to the JVM, right?
So it cannot run on Android.
So there can't be ways to
do that, to work with Scala,
but it's using
third-parties libraries.
So you have classes that were
made by people to word the Java
classes but then it becomes
tricky to integrate that
cleanly with that Android Studio
that the [INAUDIBLE] quickly.
So I'm not sure it's as
complicated as creating
a whole new language like Apple
did, but I think, I don't know,
my question was just if you
guys were considering and uh--
XAVIER DUCROHET: I think from
the tool perspective, probably
later this year,
or early next year,
there are some changes
going on inside Grata
right now that will make
things easier to you
to just have a module that's
originally written in Scala
and then complied
down to byte code
and then we can just
text that and package
that with your application.
But it's not going to help you
access like the activity API
through Scala code.
Right?
It would be if you have some
code that your Business Logic
or whatever that you want to
write in Scala because it's
easier for you, you
should be able to do that.
Because, as you said,
it's compatible in just
regular byte code and
then just texting it.
But that's very
different from saying
you can could code
Android in Java
where you have access to
all the framework API.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
RETO MEIER: Thanks From
the back of the room.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Yeah.
I was wondering some
of the newer features
in Android L, for example, like
the notifications on the home
screen.
How much control will
the user have over that?
And I mean, I went to the What's
New In Android session earlier
and they talked about
how, as the app developer
I will have the option of
setting privacy levels.
But let's imagine
for a second, that I
don't think that a third
party developer knows
what I think is appropriate for
displaying on my home screen.
Will I be able to, say,
turn those off entirely?
GABE COHEN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Oh, and
just my two cents,
I think the new app ops of
the Play Store permissions
are kind of confusing,
actually, and they kind of
obfuscate a lot of
things that I don't think
should be obfuscated.
[APPLAUSE]
RETO MEIER: Thank you for
that feedback and to Chet
for not explaining the
notification things well enough
in the earlier session.
Front of the room.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
So Kit Kat did an exceptional
job of making Android svelte,
I guess.
And with L's new focus on lush
animation and 3-D rendered
shadows and everything
that's beautiful,
I was wondering how
like emerging market
devices and older devices
will fare with it?
Yeah.
ADAM POWELL: So when
some of the engineers who
are working on some of
the flashier features
that you've been seeing
in here first started,
this was something that we
thought was really important.
We didn't want to make a
move like this in KitKat,
only to just kind of toss
it out as soon as we found
some new, flashy effects
we wanted to implement.
So they'd actually found
the absolute oldest devices
they could, sitting
around in a desk
that we still had drivers for.
And they actually
started on those devices
to implement these effects.
So this is the sort of thing
where performance on low end
devices is something
that was really
intrinsic to the initial
design of the implementation.
So there's definitely a few
cases, a bunch of you're
going to get the L preview
and go run some of it.
You'll probably run into some
cases where you say, oh, wait,
this is a little bit
slower than I thought.
We know about them already.
We're working on them.
Many of them
actually have already
been addressed internally as
we've continued along this.
So performance is something that
we think is really important.
We can't really accomplish
the goal of material design
if everything is just
janking across the screen
the whole time.
DAVE BURKE: Yeah.
I'd just add that
we still literally
have a weekly meeting
on Svelte, so kind
of monitoring the memory.
We don't want to go backward.
And then Art, the
runtime is actually
more memory efficient
than Dalvik.
Well we have different
types of garbage collectors
but there's a moving
collector that's
used when your app
goes in the background.
It's slower.
So you don't want to do
it in the foreground.
But it will save like
hundreds of kilobytes easily.
So it's helping us too.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Related question.
We had a project
about a Svelte folder.
What comes first,
the name or the idea?
DAVE BURKE: Genuis.
The idea.
ADAM POWELL: There was
that one where you just
had to come up with a
project for the name though.
DAVE BURKE: Project Project.
[LAUGHTER]
RETO MEIER: From the
back of the room.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about Google Play services.
We want to use services like
Google Analytics, Drive, AdMob,
across all Android
devices including
those without Google Play.
These services used
to be individual jars.
But now are part of
Google Play services.
How do you propose we use these
services across all Android
devices?
[APPLAUSE]
GABE COHEN: Did you ask this
question in the Google Play
Services rocks?
AUDIENCE: I didn't
but someone else did.
GABE COHEN: Someone else did.
OK.
I heard the same question.
I'm afraid I don't have
much to add to the answer.
So all of us here work in the
compatible device ecosystem
devices with Google Play.
So our primary concern
is how this platform
is expressed on those devices.
We actually don't
really have any opinion
on what other
organizations in Google
do with devices outside
of our ecosystem.
So it's kind of a question,
I think, for somebody
from the analytics
and the AdMob team.
I don't think I can answer that.
Sorry.
RETO MEIER: From the
front of the room.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Ever since Cupcake, or
versions before that.
I'm not that old anyway.
I've been using
BroadcastReceiver
to do fun things with
getting SMS messages.
But these days everyone uses
Hangouts, which is awesome.
But should I just
give up on trying
to have an application interact
with Hangout's messages
or-- Could someone
comment on what
I should do in that regard?
DIANNE HACKBORN:
I think if you're
talking about what happened in
KitKat with the change in how
the messaging is, so you
have a preferred messaging
application?
AUDIENCE: Not so much.
More on just a sense
of like the fact
that Hangout's messages don't
trigger an SMS broadcast out
to other applications.
DIANNE HACKBORN: People
are not using SMS.
Yeah if they're
not using SMS then
the platform won't
know about it and--
AUDIENCE: OK With
Hangout, people,
apps can't respond to
messages as they come in
through the API?
RETO MEIER: I think
that's unfortunately
more of a question for
someone on the Hangout team
rather than Android
framework team.
So,
ADAM POWELL: From
the perspective
of the framework though,
this is the sort of thing
where, if an application
was implementing
messaging that moves
over its own protocols
over the internet,
then that application
would be totally free to publish
their own broadcast if they so
chose.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
RETO MEIER: From the
back of the room.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I wanted to ask you
guys, what's the status,
and if you do, for the Wi-Fi
peer to peer tools for Android?
Because as a developer
that has worked with them,
I know that the technology has
a great potential but right now
these tools seem very
incomplete and very buggy.
So I wanted to know if there are
plans to replicate or continue
developing whatever.
DAVE BURKE: Oh, Yeah they
are a little bit but buggy.
I agree.
We're actually scaling
that team so we've
been hiring lots of people.
Wireless in general.
Actually so like trying
to really invest a lot
more in Bluetooth and Wi-Fi
and cellular and Volke
and all of stuff.
So no plan to duplicate
peer to peer Wi-Fi.
There's some new
Wi-Fi features coming.
I mean you can see some of the
standards in Wi-Fi Alliance,
like Network Neighborhood,
things like that.
I'm trying to think what else
we're doing in that space.
We're actually doing a lot
of refactoring internally
on Wi-Fi.
So previously in
releases to Supplicant,
the WPA Supplicant had
a lot of the logic.
We've actually sort
of taken the logic
and moved it up and rewritten
the parts of the Wi-Fi state
machine and then we've
introduced a new Wi-Fi
How to abstract
out Wi-Fi features.
Like, for example, Devices
Scan for Locations.
Today they scan all the
channels now with the new Wi-Fi
How, we can selectively scan.
Anyway, the point I'm
making is that we're
investing in that area and so
we're trying to improve it.
AUDIENCE: OK.
RETO MEIER: Thanks, Dave.
A question here from online.
Which is the most
important thing
to focus on when you're
first creating an app.
Should it be the
engineering or the design?
JHILMIL JAIN: You're thinking
about this the wrong way.
You should really be
focusing on the user.
RETO MEIER: Nice.
I see what you did there.
DAVE BURKE: User design.
JHILMIL JAIN: Sure.
RETO MEIER: Moving on.
Someone from the
back of the room.
JHILMIL JAIN: I think like
even for a number of products
that we talked about today,
where automotive, TV,
it didn't really start just
with the design or whatever.
Coding really started
with really looking
at some fundamental issues
that are currently the wrong,
our products are not meeting
when users are concerned
and really trying to be
really clever about how can we
build a product that really
solves those issues for users.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much for
thinking so much about design
with the new release.
It's very exciting.
I think that I probably
speak for a number of people
though when we go and
talk to our design teams
about the new looks and the
new ways of doing things.
They will pull out a
Galaxy S4 and they'll
show us the text messaging
app and they'll say,
you think Android has a
consistent design language.
And yet this is my
text messaging app.
We're going to design it the
way we want to design it.
What steps are you
taking or thinking
of taking to address the kind
of crazy design ecosystem that
exists in the Android world?
[APPLAUSE]
RACHEL GARB: One step that we
can take that will help this,
I think, is to do a better
job with our own applications.
Following our own
design guidelines.
[APPLAUSE]
That's something that we've
been working on for a while.
You know we're a big company.
We've got close to
100 teams that we're
working with that are
developing Android
apps all across the company.
And they're all on
different release schedules.
So it's a bit of a challenge.
Plus as you can see, we're also
evolving our design guidelines
too.
And that happens
usually internally first
and then externally.
But one of things about that
strategy of starting internally
is it means that by the time
the guidelines are rolled out
you have some concrete
examples to work with,
which we know is
really important.
RETO MEIER: Thank you.
In the front.
AUDIENCE: First thank you
all for all your hard work
building a platform
that so many of us
can create a career around.
My question is as a developer,
I personally experience
a lot of pain points
and hear about a lot
of pain around testing,
particularly unit testing
in Android.
I feel like solutions
like Robilectric
feel more like a bandaid
than a proper solution
for the problem.
Can you speak to maybe
anything in the L preview
or just a general idea around
testing, particularly unit
testing in Android.
[APPLAUSE]
XAVIER DUCROHET: So
first, we do want
to help Robilectric
to integrate better
with our current set of tools.
We know it's
definitely a bandaid,
that it's not a
perfect solution.
But like a lot of teams
currently rely on it,
so we want to improve the
solutions there so for people
who want to use it, they
can actually use it.
For the rest, anything that
doesn't run on an Android
device is going to be a bandaid.
I mean, if you have some code
that's purely non-Android
and can run on the
VM, then you should
be able to create a Java module
and test your logic there.
For the thing that
access the Android API,
you should run it on a device.
Now the problem is that
it is slow to deploy
It is slow to build.
And to run the test.
On the build and deploy, on
the build, at least part,
we are trying to
improve the situation
to build faster with
greater [INAUDIBLE].
There's some work
going on in there.
That will get better some time.
The deploy part is
more complicated.
And it's something
that we want to tackle,
but it's like we need
to work with the runtime
to be able to do that.
So it does nothing in L
that would help with that.
But in your existing Android
API, there is no other way.
You need to run on a device to
make sure that it is actually
reliable, as far as
the test results.
RETO MEIER: Thank you.
From the back of the room.
AUDIENCE: Like
many apps displays,
text and images for which we
employ text views, and image
views, and layouts, we were not
aware of a general purpose way
to wrap text around images.
And we're not satisfied
with third party libraries
that we researched at the time.
So about a year ago, we
developed our own overriding
canvas.
It was complicated.
It was difficult to test.
And lately we're
revisiting the code
and wishing that our app didn't
have to do all this work.
Is the Android team
looking at this problem?
ADAM POWELL: So the
short answer is yes.
I think that it's something
that we've definitely
seen as a pain point in
a number of apps that
have come to us asking questions
about how to do exactly
the sorts of things
that you've described.
And for all the reasons that
I'm sure that you've already
run into you've
realized that it's
a fairly complicated
problem space.
Now a lot of that just
comes from the way
that text views interaction
with canvas and the way
that it deals with text and
fonts and so on and so forth
is complicated,
to say the least.
But it's also very
tightly coupled right now.
And in the future we'd
really like to work on that
and see if there's anything
that we can do to sort of tease
that apart into some modules
that can be used a little bit
more naturally to accomplish
the types of things
you're talking about.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
RETO MEIER: One of
questions online.
It's colorfully asked, so I'll
try to rephrase it slightly.
Dan is wondering, do
you see a possibility
of having the ability to do a
full build and test environment
within the Chrome OS 400?
[APPLAUSE]
DAVE BURKE: So I don't know.
I think that means an
ID within Chromo S.
FICUS KIRKPATRICK:
The ethos of Chrome OS
is that the ID would
be like in the cloud
somewhere, right I don't
know if there's anything that
makes sense to say we've
made an ID for Chrome OS
that they couldn't
use from any browser.
RETO MEIER: Question
to the cloud team.
We saw a little stuff from them
on like IDEs for cloud apps.
I don't see building
Android apps
in the cloud happening soon.
XAVIER DUCROHET:
I mean, you also
have to look at deployment.
I would guess that
a lot of developers
right now mostly
use devices to test.
If you're bringing in the cloud,
and your application is not
a small, Hello
World, application
you're going to
have to be download
that APK on your local
device every time you build.
And if your app
is 10 megs and you
don't have a crazy
connection, that's
just not going to work at all.
So I don't see that happening.
The current state of web ID
is just the beginning of it.
If you compare that to a really
good Java ID like IntelliJ
it just doesn't compare.
So I think that test of IDs are
still the way to go for now.
RETO MEIER: Thank you.
Let's see.
From the front.
AUDIENCE: Like most of
the people in this room,
I'm really excited to see
that there's an L preview
release this time around.
And by the fact that it's coming
out as factory images only,
it's pretty clear
that it's only meant
for developers and
extreme enthusiasts, who
want to get a real jump on it.
Is this a pattern
that we can expect
to see in the future,
more preview releases?
Because I've seen a lot of
complaints from more normal,
average users who are
running into problems
with the early versions
of each major release.
DAVE BURKE: Yeah
I think it's funny
that this idea everybody
claims to be their idea
and pushed for it.
So I'm going to claim was
my idea and pushed for it.
But it wasn't as
everyone's idea.
I think one of the
observations I had was just
that the platforms,
it's getting so big.
Right?
That the surface
area is so large.
We do, we've got
a great QA team.
And we do, we test the top 1,000
apps and all this good stuff.
Got a CTS tasks but this
is the long tale of apps.
You just can't test everything.
And so what ends up happening
is you would make a release
and you break something.
And it's just, I remember
triaging the bugs post
JBMR2 for KitKat.
And it was just embarrassing.
It was like, you
should've caught this.
It was clear to me that we had
to move to this model, where
we put out the developer
preview, where people can test
their apps, submit bugs,
and when we fix things.
So, I think, obviously
I can't make promises
but I think the
reason we've done
it is a very rational reason,
and entropy, increases
not decreases.
So I think we shall continue
doing it most likely, possibly
not promising, but yes.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: And to that I
say, thank you so much.
Thank you.
RETO MEIER: What
do you guys think?
Do you like having
the preview releases?
DAVE BURKE: And the
other thing I hope to see
is actually to get OEM as
a jump in building devices.
Because once we make
the preview available
we don't have to
be so secretive.
We can share our builds.
We can share more source.
We can look at
vendors and stuff.
So my hope is that when L comes
out officially in the fall,
that a bunch of
devices pass follow.
So we'll see how that
pounds out this year.
XAVIER DUCROHET: I just
to point out quickly
that there will be
a [INAUDIBLE] system
images of available as well.
So if you can use
that if needed.
RETO MEIER: From the
back of the room.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I really like the new
Grata Build System.
It's really awesome.
You can do really
awesome things with it.
But I'm not really an
intelligent user nor will
I see myself being
one in the future.
Is Eclipse going to become the
redheaded stepchild of Android
or is there going to be support
for it continuing forward?
XAVIER DUCROHET: Did
you see the time, Reto?
[LAUGHTER]
RETO MEIER: Thanks everyone.
We don't even have time to
open a Java form on Eclipse.
[LAUGHTER AND GROANS]
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but
you don't have time
to build an Android app
in IntelliJ in this time.
AUDIENCE: No, I get it.
DAVE BURKE: Think it's tricky.
An ideal world will
support all IDs.
But we sort of have to
pick one to double down on.
And I think we're starting
to pull down on IntelliJ.
So.
Yeah.
XAVIER DUCROHET:
There's actually
some work going on
with Grata on Eclipse
to try to improve to
the integration there.
I mean separate from Android.
Also there's some work
happening in Grata
itself to improve
their internal model
so that's our
model can be closer
or more compatible with theirs.
And so if both of
those things happen,
then you could
potentially at least,
open and Android Grata
base project inside Eclipse
and do at least
basic job editing
with all of the
dependencies working
and possibly just build out.
You wouldn't have any Android
specific feature tied to Grata
but it might actually work.
But as they've said, it would
be nice to support every ID,
but right now we're
focusing on Studio.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
for everything you do.
RETO MEIER: Thanks.
We are completely out of time.
So thank you, everyone
for your great questions.
[APPLAUSE]
And thank everyone on stage
for joining us and answering
everything so open.
So thank you.